there's a storm brewing across the
Atlantic called Daniels and she makes
Katrina look like an April shower I'm
talking about the revelations by adult
film actress stormy Daniels of her
alleged affair with Donald Trump and
sleazy as it is our fascination with
political sex scandals is in danger of
distracting us from the real problems a
trump's presidency faces it's not often
that you'll find me defending Donald
Trump but he's never misrepresented
himself perhaps politicians had
previously been held to an unattainable
standard and Trump's undignified
behavior has brought our expectations of
those in public office down to earth
with a thud now I look forward to the
day when Donald J Trump is out of the
White House and back on the golf course
for good but if anything brings Trump
down it should be his performance in
office rather than in any other room
compared to all the potential
inadequacies of Trump's presidency
I think this scandal is more and I
borrowed from my dear friend Nick
Ferrari a storm in a d-cup
[Music]
I'm just when you go adult would she
play a rabbit or something like that
saying something but just you said you
never thought that you would necessarily
be a defendant I I was a mild fan at one
point but actually all hail President
Obama and her because he sailed through
two terms and there was never a whiff of
scandal and I think that is to be
applauded and does it mean yes I think
you're probably right I think that
politicians are by and large held to to
higher standard they only reflect
Society yes so there are some reggae
presenters who live some rather dodgy
backgrounds there are some radio within
digit of tremendous man some journalists
have rather dodgy background I know some
journalists who we can admire and I
think it is the same apology and what
worries me is there could be somebody
out there who could hold the solution to
the problems in the Middle East and they
look at it and I think actually I don't
have the greatest background I am a bit
of a a bit of a boy or a bit of a girl
and I'm not why do I want to put my head
above the pack and that's what concerns
me
actually I'd like to bring in but look
what happened to my old friend Toby
Young who they dug ups and historic
tweets and he was actually running the
new schools Network which is a
government-funded charity you're right
and people aren't going to want to enter
public life you blaming dad you can't
blame you know what you know I think
storm Thomas I rather liked her the fact
that she was straight on there she said
I'm not a victim don't class me with me
- I'm not a victim in that one dead
shell she said it was ended up in a room
with a creepy old man who offered me or
hinted that he might give her a turn on
the apprentice yes she said I slept with
him and she actually said I have not
made nearly enough money out of this yet
she straight on deny she even and I
loved it I loved that line in the story
where she when she met it was she
offered to spank his backside see if any
of this is actually harm Trump in any
way because the truth is if you look at
this there's been absolutely zero change
on his approval ratings if you look at
39% of people then thirty nine percent
approve now the only difference has been
is less people disapprove child of
Florence Nightingale I'm really glad you
raised this yeah because actually it's a
brave topic for you to raise people will
accuse you're defending trouble the
truth is actually as you and I know it
used to be conservatives that used to
pry into liberals private lives and and
moralize about it when since when were
liberals about moralizing about personal
sexual conduct yeah and unfortunately if
parties and politics has got in the way
and they've offended their values I
personally think that a politician's
private life as long as they're not
breaking the law have to be very careful
because in spending so much time on this
actually it takes away from the real
stuff and you're the problem isn't
what's - me - Tommy Daniels it wasn't
just a one-night you know when I stand
and in exchange for telling the
apprentice she afterwards she
Edge's she was approached in the carpark
threatened her daughter was and so too
is threatened you know she was
apparently a nice people paid off by his
lawyer which could be a campaign funding
issue and also but I think you're right
in the sense that Trump has never hidden
the fact that he's basically a sexual
I'm allowed to say sexual predator
because he said you know as we remember
I passed on kissing them it's like a
magnet just kiss I don't even wake when
when you're a star they let you do it
you can do anything grab them by that
yet you can do anything you know who
we're dealing and I suppose it's all
been baked into the Trump profiling you
know this is what Trump had to say about
his own alleged peccadilloes that was
locker room talk I'm not proud of it I
am a person who has great respect for
people from my family for the people of
this country and certainly I'm not proud
of it but that was something that
happened and if the stormy Daniels was
just a storm in a d-cup
why did the u.s. expel sixty diplomats
as an amazing dead cat diversionary
tactic when tonight that she's just
before any attorney as they calm over
there gets too excited we're not of
course suggesting that the president is
a sexual predator let's hear from White
House principal deputy press secretary
Raj Shah on this with respect to that
interview I will say the president
strongly clearly and has consistently
denied these underlying claims and the
only person who's been inconsistent is
the one making the claims and a story
isn't a story without a tweet from the
president so let's see what Donald Trump
has said so much fake news never been
more voluminous or more inaccurate but
through it all our country is doing
great which coming back to your central
point actually by many indicators if we
now go to or at the stockmarket FinTech
is off a little bit but if we go to job
creation if we go by and large its
creation 17-year low more people agree
with what he's doing with the economy
than don't that's not that's not my
point with with Trump but my point here
is we're putting so much focus on all of
this nonsense when actually what we
should be looking at is what's going on
in terms of the spending of the family
what's going on with
Russia there were more important things
where he's concerned that we should be
looking at but not who he dated him to
that he's and thinks what he worries
about is what people at home think of
them you know he's he cares about
America and the people in America like
what he's doing I mean you said his
approval rating hasn't read it has
actually since February it's gone up
seven points it went down and now it's
gone up again so the people have voted
from still one of them concern is it
will the office of presidency ever be
seen in the same way which you know you
mentioned Obama and President Obama and
I had many criticisms of Obama's foreign
policy especially in Syria but you're
right his president is his sell-by it
looks like a golden era now compared to
what we're seeing of the president you
know and I just wonder because we had
that in Britain our politics we we had
we actually had a lack of deference to
our politicians we've had that for a
long time and we were met with scandal
after scandal and people don't really
admire and look up to their politician
employers whereas America had something
different the office of the White House
was a prestigious and an honorable
position to hold and I wonder if it's
become more British in that sense he is
literally a one-off
well it's why we don't know we don't
know until the next person comes in we
don't laugh example you shouldn't that
typically with it with with I thought
who's that I thought and then you
mentioned they were thought now I know
because he's had sack so many people yes
and that the revolving door and his
staffers so I don't even know who that
was anymore
I live of Roseanne Barr that's it he's
the president and we're in a war so you
know I think we should all pull together
and
try to get over our Great Divide we'd
watch the stormy Daniels interview last
night now I don't
so obviously Roseanne Barr is the
comedian and what's interesting about it
generally terrible oh yeah she says we
should all get together interesting with
Roseanne is her TV show just returned
came back on air this week and it's the
highest-rated show in six years highest
rated scripted show in six years and the
family are a pro Trump family so that's
quite interesting maybe what you're
saying is true